escribe los siguientes números como
números complejos
ok como pequeño recordatorio para
escribir un número complejo lo tenemos
que escribir con su parte real y su
parte imaginaria o sea si ponemos
variables un número complejo se ve más o
menos de la forma a más b x y x y donde
a yb esos números reales y este numerito
de acá es la unidad imaginaria y vale a
esta parte a la que no tiene y se le
conoce como la parte real hasta aquí es
la parte real del número complejo y esta
parte de acá es la parte imaginaria
imaginaria
y es la parte imaginaria simplemente
porque es una versión a escala de la
unidad imaginaria de y para acordarnos
está y era un número tal que al elevarlo
al cuadrado nos daba igual a menos 1 y
esto era algo nuevo porque antes no
teníamos números que al elevar los al
cuadrado nos dieran menos 1 tener este
número es muy útil porque ahora vamos a
poder obtener la raíz cuadrada de muchos
otros números de números negativos y con
eso vamos a poder resolver varias
ecuaciones que antes no podíamos hacer
cuando nada más teníamos los números
reales esto está súper padre porque
luego tiene consecuencias en ingeniería
en física y en otras áreas pero por el
momento nada más nos vamos a concentrar
en estas dos definiciones y después vas
a encontrarle un poco más de valor a
este número y ya los números imaginarios
en general bueno entonces vamos al
problema dice escribe los siguientes
números como números complejos ok
este menos 21 pues se ve muy solito
verdad nada más es como la parte real de
un número complejo tenemos que ponerle
su parte imaginaria entonces déjame
escribirlo así
vamos a escribirlo como -21 esa es la
parte real pero luego vamos a sumar 0
veces la parte imaginaria
si ves por si ves por qué dice eso
porque 0 por y es 0 entonces esto sigue
siendo un -21 pero ahora ya tiene una
parte imaginaria y entonces ya está
escrito como un número complejo de
manera similar podemos resolver el de
abajo ahora tenemos nada más la parte
imaginaria nos falta la parte real
entonces en la parte real vamos a poner
un cero y a eso vamos a sumarle 7 y y
listo con esto ya quedó en forma
compleja con su parte real y con su
parte imaginaria